alex auld avec l'autriche c'est pas très
loin de la france voilà un homme qui
remporte assez largement les élections
après avoir été mis aux affaires
étrangères et s'être avoir bâti sa
campagne sur sa capacité à couper
l'immigration en particulier celle des
qui venait par les balkans il pourrait
faire un accord électoral avec un parti
d'extrême droite le fp fo qui lui même
est très très haut ce qui va plus du
presque 26 % quasiment autant que les
sociaux démocrates
pourquoi est ce que la droite triomphe
en autriche alors qu'en france elle est
en lambeaux je pense que la france et
contra cyclique donald trump a gagné aux
états unis et theresa may triomphe quand
même plus ou mois en angleterre sur fond
de briques cité aujourd'hui on a
souscrit nomen là on ne triche donc je
pense qu'on a toujours un décalage de
dix ans quand il y avait un reagan et
thatcher ou pouvoir on allait françois
mitterrand aujourd'hui on à emmanuel
macron pas ce qui est intéressant de
voir c'est que sans doute futur
chancelier autrichien à gagner face à
une coalition gauche-droite finalement
face et une politique libérale
européenne assez proche de ce que fait
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui donc je
pense que emmanuel macron dans le futur
libéra effectivement un espace pour une
droite protectionnistes régulatrice
assez dur sur les questions
d'immigration ça paraît aujourd'hui leur
logique et d'une certaine manière
peut-être que l'autriche est un
laboratoire pour la droite française de
demain